Barry Melrose back here on the show how
are you Barry great rich how are you
please put in perspective best you can
what's going on in Vegas Barry you know
what I don't think you can I think that
this is uncharted territory this has
never happened before in any sport it
certainly never happened in the NHL
nothing has come close to this happening
in NHL we're an expansion team in the
first year of being a team goes to
Stanley Cup Finals and I'd like to put
in perspective like this the Toronto
Maple Leafs who are the wealthiest team
in the NHL are worth more than any other
team in the NHL have had every resource
a team could possibly have and they
haven't played for the Stanley Cup since
1966 and and that just sort of shows how
rare and how hard it is to get two
Stanley Cup Finals and here Vegas with a
bunch of guys that their teams didn't
want our four wins away from winning the
Stanley Cup so it's just a phenomenal
story it's it's been picking up legs all
throughout the United States and Canada
and everyone's writing about it and
everyone's got a few up on it and it's
just a magnificent story it's just an
unbelievable story what Vegas has done
well in terms of the view upon it Barry
we're hearing a lot certainly since the
Vegas Golden Knights knocked off
Winnipeg here in a lot that the rules
for the expansion draft were tilted in
their favor we had George McPhee the
general manager on the show yesterday he
said that the rules were more fair is
how he put it and then also said that
for those complaining about it they
weren't complaining about the 17 million
dollar check that they received for the
expansion fee where do you stand on that
subject I'm with George 100% I think in
the old days the expansion teams were
base Irae they got the the players that
no one wanted the rules are so stacked
against them they had no chance of being
good so the other owners one of their
cake and eat it too they wanted to get
the check but they also wanted the new
team coming in to be bad so he holds so
finally these guys are spending a half a
billion dollars or more to get an
expansion team finally are getting some
decent players and the thing is they're
not they're not
and you know that the top six forwards
are the top three defense when they're
getting you know good young players it's
up to Vegas to pick these players and
and make the deals to get these players
and now you want to punish and say that
it's not fair because Vegas has done a
good job you can't have it both ways and
and so I'm with George McVie a thousand
percent I think the rules were fair I
think that Vegas did their job better
than the teams that that are existing
teams and now those teams that can't get
the Stanley Cup Finals want to sort of
belittle what Vegas is done I don't
think that's right whatsoever I'm
interesting enough bury a team that the
Vegas could be facing his McPhee's
former team and he was a GM for so long
he drafted Ovechkin as we all know and
and taps fans also know and hockey fans
hear it about the tortured history of
the caps Ovechkin and Nick Backstrom
each have seven games seven losses which
is tied for most by any player in the
history of the NHL postseason how real
is the mental aspect of expecting it and
not getting over the hump berry how real
is that well I think this team is
different than than Washington teams in
the past this year in the playoffs
whenever they've got to a point where
they it's a must-win game they had it in
the first round they had in the second
round they've obviously had it a couple
times in the third round
this team rises to the occasion like
last night they they were the better
team and they've been the better team
throughout this series of the six games
I think Washington's been the better
team four times a little six game and
also you know they're just a team that
playing great Ovechkin's had a great
series a great playoffs
backs from playing with a broken hand
and had still got two assists last night
Braden Holtby who wasn't even the
starting goaltender the first two games
of the playoffs is playing awesome right
now
you know Kuznetsov is emerging as a
superstar in the NHL
last night they played a very physical
style they came out and pounded Tampa
Bay physically with you know 15 20 great
hits the hits were 39 20 19 in that game
in favor of the Washington Capitals
and the Washington Capitals about shot
Tampa in every game so far in the third
round so this was different Washington
team we've seen in the past those teams
whenever they got to a point where they
had to win the game they always lost now
this team when they have to win a game
they find a way to win it so this is a
different Washington team than we've
seen over the last decade in the NHL all
that said Barry Melrose what happens in
Game seven do you think tomorrow night
well I I've been on I've been on the
Tampa bandwagon all year long I think
it's a great team I think they're going
to respond I think they were embarrassed
with what happened last night
Game seven is in their building I know
that's not advantage I think the
visiting teams are winning more right
now than the home team's but I think the
Tampa will rebound and and play a great
game and and win the series but this
Washington team I would not be at all
surprised that they go on but I think
Tampa will find a way to win this game
seven well we haven't spoken in a brief
bit so you know a couple of things have
happened since we last spoke what do you
think of Marchand given a given a little
lick what you thought oh I thought it
was brutal I think it was cute for a
little while
gave people a lot to talk about but
everybody got sick of it it basically at
the same time and the NHL stepped in and
told the Marshawn that this is not
acceptable and not to do it anymore so
probably I thought they should have done
it before that but they did make it
right and and then thing is of Marshawn
he doesn't need that stuff this guy is a
great hockey player he's one of the the
best players in the NHL's he doesn't
need to do that crap
after the whistles and in the pile on so
I was glad at the NHL stepped forward
and told them that this isn't acceptable
and not to do it anymore so but that
said Barry and you'll have to excuse me
it seems all he got was a tongue lashing
use it Barry please go and use it in two
different continents go are too much in
any of my commentary I don't know I'll
find a way to work again but really I'll
Drive there you go I mean shouldn't they
have just slapped him down already I
mean that that is yes yes they should
have they should have they should have
acted before they did but you know
he has been a repeat offender for
different things not anything like that
for a physical play but you know it's
the old saying it's better late than
never and it was the right decision made
so I'll get the NHL some slack over that
okay and and what's the biggest
disappointment so far in these playoffs
that you think is going to have a
lasting effect going into next season so
I you know I think maybe Pittsburgh I
think you know we sort of were hoping
that they could be one of the teams it
could maybe read three-peat
it's so rare these days that just
doesn't happen they look like they were
set up to do that but they couldn't get
by Washington and there's an example of
why this Washington seems different than
other Washington teams Pittsburgh was
always able to be Washington in these
series and and though they were one of
the reasons that Alex and Nicki have
that terrible you know seven seven game
seven losing streak that they have that
you mentioned but you know I think I was
open more for Pittsburgh they went out
pretty easily in that second round but
again I think that's a tribute to
Washington not a reason to question
Pittsburgh we showed last one for you we
showed our television audience before
you came on a game between the Red Wings
and the Capitals on January 7th 1986
does that game ring ring a bell do you
know why we were showing that prior to
your no I can't think of it right now I
talked my head while you were showing
that mm-hmm
because it was you and uh Edie Costello
going at it that's good that's a good
research right I'll tell ya oh yeah I
mean what was that well you know do you
remember that day they always go after
the other team's best player and so
that's why I was involved obviously
that's one thing I can say I mean you
know is this the best fight you've had
or longest or what I'll tell you I'll
tell you the best fight I ever had the
NHL okay we're playing the Islanders and
this was the big Islanders when the
teams were winning the standings I was
dry for five 943 yeah and I was playing
for Detroit and I got in a fight with
Clark gillies oh and somehow I landed
lucky blow and I hit Clark in the nose
and his nose started bleeding so we go
to the penalty box and Clark is
I know Clark proposed from Saskatchewan
and stuff so Clark in the penalty box
and it was in Long Island and he's
yelling at me that he's gonna kill me
when we get back on the ice and he's
gonna do this to me he's gonna kill my
he's gonna kill my wife and then he'll
kill my family on that and and there is
there is video Clark knows plenty and
often the penalty box and him screaming
at me so that is that's one of the
highlights of my fighting curve but
everybody's safe though right Clark
didn't do anything we did yeah yeah he
didn't let he didn't didn't go on with
the threat thank God Barry you the man
thanks for joining
appreciate it Thanks anytime you got it
cuz we'll chat during the cup that's
Barry Melrose and the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience